ils ont emballé ce qu'ils pouvaient à la
hâte certains ont mis plusieurs jours
pour arriver jusqu'ici
des vieillards des mers et leurs enfants
sans oublier minou trop souvent par
contre ils sont sans impaire une mère un
fils laissé derrière ils ont tenu sous
l'occupation russe pendant des mois
aujourd'hui c'est leur dernière chance
d'y échapper croient l'Aude Mila plutôt
que les chars et les soldats Ukrainiens
qu'elle espérait ce sont les boîtes d'un
scrutin référendaire russe pour
l'annexion à la Russie de sa vulkerson
qui est la vue débarquer
ils vont de maisons en maison pour
recueillir des signatures avec l'armée
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord il menace
votre famille nous en avons conclu qu'il
ne nous restait que quelques jours pour
partir je ne veux pas voter dans leur
référendum alors ils vont me menacer
impossible de s'exprimer librement quand
on vous demande de voter avec les armes
qui vous menacent une conclusion à
laquelle une majorité est arrivée ici
relatant des scènes similaires à ces
images que l'on voit circuler sur les
réseaux sociaux depuis quelques jours
dans les ondes séparatistes et sous
occupation russe
beaucoup confirme les accusations de
l'Ukraine
forcez la participation référendum
qualifié de simulacre par la communauté
internationale c'est directement chez
les gens accompagnés de soldats
lourdement armés que le vote se déroule
Timothée dit qu'il a bien compris la
menace
sont sortis qu'ils ont dit qu'il était
du FSB les services de renseignement
russe je ne suis qu'un fonctionnaire
ukrainien raconte l'homme j'étais à 600
rien faire mais je ne pouvais pas partir
ma mère est trop vieille malade je ne
pouvais pas l'abandonner mais j'ai dû le
faire parce qu'ils apportaient un ordre
urgent de prendre un passeport russe de
travailler et de voter en faveur de
l'annexion référendum en quoi ils m'ont
dit que notre conversation serait bien
différente
après sa mère laissez derrière dans la
région de Milito Paul il se sépare
aujourd'hui de sa femme qui va vivre à
Odessa lui espère pouvoir retrouver sa
mère tous ceux qui nous avons parlé ici
refusent de participer au référendum un
exercice sur lequel il ne pense pas
pouvoir avoir un impact mais surtout il
craignent les conséquences d'une
annexion à la Russie
nous avons tous peur de devoir combattre
nos propres frères vive Vladimir qui a
mis deux jours sur la route avant
d'arriver à zaporigia
série yoga ne veut pas être identifié il
a laissé une partie de sa famille
derrière comme beaucoup d'hommes dit-il
qui veulent t'éviter d'être conscrits
par l'armée russe après le référendum le
scénario est écrit d'avance par la
Russie il ne veut pas du rôle qu'on lui
attribué
avec leurs armes automatiques qu'est-ce
qu'un homme peut faire contre des armes
qui n'a pas et même avec ils sont 10
contre 1 ou 2 on pourrait se rebeller
mais après ils vont liquider le village
la néantine c'est effrayant
Natacha et sa famille reprennent des
forces avant de poursuivre la route pour
rejoindre des proches à Odessa en
attendant dit-elle mais elle redoute que
d'ici quelques jours à peine la maison
qu'elle laisse derrière ne se retrouve
en territoire russe
il nous faudra dire à dieuditel c'est
déchirant c'était effrayant quand on a
l'habitude de vivre dans sa maison dans
son environnement dans sa ville avec son
peuple de tout abandonner dans le
rétroviseur
mais c'est là dans le rétroviseur
qu'elle fixe encore son regard on n'est
jamais tout à fait prêt pour des racines
de